greetings adventurers greetings as you
all can see here we have a new traveler
in our ranks this is my cousin Tyrell
and he will be controlling the player
character his name is Kanye he's a giant
you know dear cousin traditionally a
giant is not as sued by a player it is a
chaotic evil but I want to be a giant yo
I'll big ok fine well travelers you are
a joy to our adventure today by a giant
named Kanye now when last we left you if
you were at the end of the North Star in
the town of fizzled or how do you begin
your adventure I want to get some
[ __ ] where the club a tseldora
time oh this is highly unusual I think
the guys probably just want to go on the
quest that we've all taken this I'd like
to join Kanye the giant of this quest
seriously
alright the two of you enter it severed
what do you say Kanye the giant orders
alizée hmm
says the barkeep I know not of this
foreign beverage of which you speak
perhaps you'd enjoy it Eldon ale no we
both want the Alice a Alice a does not
exist in this world Kanye the giant
slabs that [ __ ] Oh
Cudi the giant attempts to slap the
bartender here the bartender is half
Hobbit and very nimble so you're going
to have to roll at 18 or above the hint
20 blue slap that hobbits coffee oh okay
called the cleric would you care to
restrained Katya the giant before the
town guard is called I grab money out of
the register called the cleric is lawful
good this act of thievery would dishonor
his gods hey man the only guys is money
and [ __ ] - I accept Kanye the Giants
gods and yeah I steal some of the money
- you - okay would you dial like to
continue your quest for the lands of
tell Dahar fellows
we came here for [ __ ] where the
[ __ ] at all right you see a bevy of
well-endowed wenches great I grabbed em
[ __ ] and we all go on my SUV fine
caddy the giant regard the dwarf and
gollin the cleric climb into his SUV
with their [ __ ] and their ill-gotten
gains and I Allah's A+ Kanye the giant
puts his demo CD in the sea no he
doesn't there are no CDs in this world
you know what do whatever you want
I I guess I'm the dungeon master now the
higher boater opens up 16 titties fall
out
you